lance lynn going to the mound this is
his 28th start his era 272. it's been a
great year for him looking for his 11th
win 172 strikeouts in 152 innings and
right-handers hitting under 200.
strike three for lynn on robbie grossman
and two down
on the mount for the tigers willie
peralta been a good fight for the tigers
he's really
shown a lot of magic his split finger
unbelievable
to right field base hit for tim anderson
chasing cameron to the warning track and
tim's got himself an easy does it double
to lead off the ball game for the sox
[Applause]
[Music]
the 2-2 grounded in the hole nice play
by goodra anderson got caught in between
scopes throw to third
and harold castro spins around to put
the tag on anderson but he's in there
safely
ground ball to short tigers had the
infield in goodram looks back anderson
what a nice job by willie peralta and
the tigers defense two away and they
keep anderson from scoring here's the
01.
popped it up
who's got it harold castro in fair
territory what a job by willie peralta
he leaves him loaded
here's the pitch
and he
clipped him
maybe on the right elbow
and the
fans don't like it
ah no jawing nothing tim to right field
again he has plugged that gap one more
time cameron gets over there on this one
and keeps tim to a single it's a two for
two night for ta7 there's the one over
robert
fly ball right field
cameron drifting over and the second
straight inning where willie peralta has
left a runner in scoring position
sends this one to left center field
robert playing on a bounce
good room with a lead off single
three and two there goes good room again
that strike three throw down to second
is high he's gonna call interference yes
they are
and he's gonna be out at second because
cameron actually
impeded the throw of yads with it being
strike three
cameron stepped in front goodrum is out
at second base yeah you really can't do
that and
a wise catcher's move is
initiate the contact if the guy even
drifts toward the flight jose brady
leads off for the white sox
jose number 30 on the way
there it goes
god bring him home
well you said before the game that
tonight would be the night for jose and
he left nothing to the imagination the
only question there
would it stay fair long enough there's
one of those sliders that doesn't do
much right up in the eyes of jose and he
decides that he's going to put an end to
the quest for 30. ninth pitch of the
at-bat on its way
to left field jimenez is over he'll play
it out of bounce
akil badu has a leadoff single here in
the tigers fourth
he's gone what a jump rondelle's throw
why even bother
grossman struck out on the cutter first
time up
now the 2-2
driven to right that's a base hit into
the corner that'll drive home the tigers
first run of the night tie it up at one
grossman scampering into second he's got
himself an rbi double
two strikes
bloop to center nicely done
two strike base hit for gavin sheets
broken bat bouncers scoped to second and
it hits the runner sheets
gavin iii
cesar to second
on the ground will hit into center field
one home sox retake the lead tim
anderson
is on his way to second and he is safe
tim beat it behind the play
racing to second
[Applause]
robert pumps this ball center field 5-2
has a play he makes the catch cesar tags
from third he scores tim into second
base and it's 3-1 socks
2-2
jose to shortstop bro comes home
and tim is underneath
tim anderson
hustling home
knew he was going to score the throw
from goodram was way too tall
another payoff
and he draws a walk
the 1-1
to right field get down and it does
grossman has to stop at second
but jonathan scope with his first hit of
the night tigers have a pair
on the base pass for miguel cabrera
tipped into the mid strike three
rough night for cabrera
[Applause]
tap to shortstop tim on the charge got a
hurry and got it there
nice
[Music]
that's a four for four for tim anderson
jose is starting to rifle the ball up
the gap in the right center
tim's around third
cut throw to the plate is cut off
and jose abreu has driven in a run in
each of his last three at bats
left field line this is fair
moncada a one-out double in the seventh
[Applause]
left field grossman to the track in the
corner that hit his glove and it's
called foul it's a foul ball
just foul in the corner one and two
grossman goes over
oh well i tell you what it looks to me
like he caught he touched that ball in
fair territory
yeah so that's exactly what it is
they're gonna figure out where the
runners need to go
maybe second and third
loop to center batu's not gonna get
there
here comes monkatta garcia scores as
well
7-1 sox with the lead
[Applause]
hernandez wants the ball to center
four straight
hits 3-1 and tim takes a walk
three-and-one
that's ball four and an rbi for abreu
[Applause]
three and two
him see you later
big win for the sox who are still alive
for the two seed